Ja.
Schön.
Guten Abend.
Ich bin Uran Apci.
Ich bin der Dienstabender der Autosstation.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Autonomie geschifert würden.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Ja, ne Menzi bitebilla.
Am Ende des Gesprächs können Sie mir fragen,
ob Sie etwas nicht verstanden.
Okay?
Ja.
Also bevor Sie mir über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen,
möchte ich ganz schnell ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Ilona Klaprot.
Ilona.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen,
Nachnamen stabilen?
Ja, der Vorname Ilona mit I-L-O-N-Za.
Ilona.
Und der Nachname Klaprot mit K-L-A-P-P-R-O-G-H.
Klaprot.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Klaprot.
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
30 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 12. März 1992.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,74 m.
Ja, 1,74 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
63 kg.
Mhm.
Und wer hat die Handynummer?
Oh, meine Handynummer weiß ich gerade nicht.
Ich habe nicht im Kopf.
Ich habe ein neues Handy.
Das muss ich gleich mal nachgucken.
Okay.
Kein Problem.
Können wir später erledigen?
Ja.
Und sind Sie verleidert?
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja.
Ein Kind, 3 Jahre alt.
3 Jahre alt.
Ein Sohn oder eine Tochter.
Okay.
Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt?
Dr. Müller.
Was sind Sie von der Beruf?
Ich bin Lehrerin von Beruf.
Mhm.
Okay.
Frau Klaprod, was für Sie zu uns?
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Ja, ich habe seit 2 Tagen habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Und die sind jetzt doch in den letzten Stunden schlimmer geworden.
Okay.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen klöstlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Langsam.
Wo genau sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Können Sie mir zeigen?
Ja, jetzt sind Sie so rechts unten,
ein bisschen unterhalb des Bauchnabels,
ein bisschen mehr rechts.
Am Anfang waren Sie mehr in der Mitte des Bauchers
und sind dann aber so ein bisschen nach rechts unten gezogen.
Jetzt unterbauch rechts.
Okay.
Wie sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Wie können Sie sich beschreiben?
Ich steche drückend.
Und eher drückend, aber dauerhaft.
So dauerhaft drückend.
Also Ihre Beschwerden, Ihre Schmerzen sind immer da.
Ja.
Es gibt etwas, das Sie Beschwerden lindert.
Ja, wenn ich mich auf die Seite lege, auf die Rechte und die Knie etwas anziehe zum Bauch,
ist es vielleicht etwas besser.
Dann habe ich eine Wärmflasche ausprobiert, aber das war nicht so gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Noch begleitende Beschwerden.
Haben Sie Erbrichtung?
Nein, aber mir ist übel.
Ich habe so Brechreiz, aber bisher habe ich nicht gebrochen.
Ich habe keine Abität.
Wie starten Sie Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzstelle von 1 bis 10?
Wenn ein leichter Schmerz ist, dann sind sie unerzüglich.
7?
7.
Können Sie Ihre Schmerzen bis Ende des Jahres besser aufhalten?
Ja, das geht.
Das wäre besser.
Und gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für die Beschwerden?
Haben Sie etwas Ungemöhnliches gegessen?
Nein, das glaube ich nicht.
Ich habe keinen Durchfall.
Sonst, wenn man mal etwas Schlechtes gegessen hat, hat man vielleicht Durchfall, habe ich aber nicht.
Nein, ich weiß Essen, glaube ich nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, woher das kommt.
Ich hatte so etwas auch vorher noch nie.
Haben Sie wegen dieser Schmerzen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Eine Schmerztablette?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Nur mit der Wärmflasche.
Die Wärmflasche habe ich ausprobiert, aber das habe ich dann schnell wieder weggelegt, weil es dann eher schlimmer wurde.
Haben Sie Piva?
Ja, ich habe es gemessen.
Vorhin habe ich gemessen vor 2 Stunden 38,5.
Im Mund habe ich gemessen.
Im Mund.
Wie hoch?
38,5.
Haben Sie Stilfrost?
Wir haben es ein bisschen, aber nicht so richtig.
Ich hatte früher mal eine Grippe, aber nicht so richtig.
Aber mir ist es warm.
Schließen Sie in den Nachtstall?
In der letzten Nacht habe ich etwas geschwitzt, was ich sonst eigentlich nicht tue.
Okay.
Haben Sie in den nächsten Monaten stark ungewöldert oder zugenommen?
Gewicht mein Körpergewicht? Nein, das habe ich gehalten.
Wiege immer 63 kg.
Wie immer.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Hat sich Ihr Appetit verändert?
Normalerweise ist der Appetit gut.
Ich vertrage vom Essen her eigentlich auch alles bis auf Erdbeeren.
Da habe ich eine Allergie.
Aber seit gestern, seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe oder seit 2 Tagen habe ich jetzt wenig gegessen, habe ich keinen Appetit.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stulkan?
Nein.
Okay.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise schlafe ich gut, aber die letzte Nacht habe ich nicht so gut geschlafen wegen der Schmerzen.
Okay.
Gibt es in Ihrer Geschichte Krankheiten, von denen ich es solle?
Ich habe eine Unterfunktion der Schilddrüse.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente?
Nehm ich ein Medikament ein, das heißt L-Theroxin 50.
Dann nehme ich eine Tablette morgens.
Eine morgens, okay.
Und noch andere Krankheiten.
Nein, ich sagte, also Allergie habe ich auf Erdbeeren und Kiwi.
Die vertrage ich dich, da kriege ich starken Ausschlag.
Also Sie reagieren auf Erdbeere.
Erdbeere und Kiwi haben einen starken Hautausschlag und jucken.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Als Kind wurde ich operiert an den Mandeln.
Da war ich glaube ich neun Jahre alt.
Aber sonst bin ich noch nie operiert worden.
Sind Sie vollständig geinholt?
Haben Sie im Buch dabei?
Nein, das habe ich nicht dabei.
Das bringt meinen Mann noch hinterher.
Ich habe es eben nicht gefunden.
Aber soweit ich weiß, bin ich gegen alle Impfungen,
die hier in Europa Sinn machen geimpft.
Auch gegen Covid.
Bin ich dreimal geimpft.
Ja, sehr gut.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, habe noch nie geraucht.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber selten.
Vielleicht in der Woche, am Wochenende mal Einglaswein.
Aber das ist nicht, glaube ich, wenig.
Ja, ich muss noch eine Frage stellen.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie Drucken?
Nein.
Das ist eine Routine.
Sie haben in Ihren Verwandtschaften Erkrankungen.
Mein Vater ist 62 Jahre alt.
Er hat eine schwere chronische Bronchitis.
Weil er sehr lange geraucht hat.
Meine Mutter ist 61 Jahre alt.
Sie hat stark brüchige Knochen.
Und auch schon Knochenbrüche gehabt.
Und sie hat Atrose an der linken Hüfte.
Die soll bald operiert werden.
Guten Besserung, Frau Flaproth.
Jeder Mutter.
Ja, dann habe ich noch einen Bruder.
Er ist 28 Jahre alt und hat eine chronische Darmenthündung.
Chronische Darmenthündung.
Sie haben ein Kind.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, das Kind ist gesund.
Das Kind ist fit.
Sie arbeiten als Lehrer.
Haben Sie viel Stress im Arbeit?
Der Beruf der Lehrerin ist anstrengend.
Da habe ich manchmal auch viel Stress.
Aber zurzeit geht es eigentlich.
Im Augenblick ist das in der Schule nicht zu viel.
Corona ist jetzt vorbei.
Das war sehr stressig mit Corona.
Wohnen Sie in einer Wohnung?
Wir wohnen in einer Wohnung.
Dreidungssichtspurt?
Manchmal jogge ich etwas.
Zweimal die Woche.
Immer eine Dreiviertelstunde.
Ich habe immer noch eine Woche.
Ich mache immer eine Dreiviertelstunde.
Dann mache ich etwas Yoga.
Frau Klaproth.
Ich habe alle meine Wettbewerbe gestellt.
Nehmen Sie bitte Platz im Wartezimmer.
Ich werde mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen.
Wie wir weiter vorgehen.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Was denken Sie, was das sein kann?
Frau Klaproth.
Wir haben immer 3 Schritte,
um eine Diagnose zu stellen.
Wir haben immer 3 Schritte, um eine Diagnose zu stellen.
Ich rufe sie wieder an und ich informiere mich, wie wir weiter vorgehen.
Gut, machen wir so.
Gut, danke.
Dann brauchen Sie jetzt fünf Minuten bis hin zum...
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe,
Sie sagten, die Schmerzen haben zur rechten Seite gewandert.
Ja.
Haben Sie in der Mitte angefangen und sind ein bisschen nach rechts gegangen?
Zwischen Nabel und Becken, ein bisschen, rechts unten?
Aber ich traf mich die Schmerzen in eine Richtung auf?
Nein.
Nein, die bleiben da in der Stellenbau.
Ich habe eine Frage gewandert oder ausstrahlen, was Unterschied gibt es diese?
Also Sie sind einmal begonnen, haben Sie mehr in der Mitte im Bauch?
Ja.
Da war das vor zwei Tagen und seit gestern sind Sie aus der Mitte so ein bisschen nach unten in den Bauch gegangen mehr.
Da sind Sie etwas gewandert der Schmerz.
Aber ausstrahlen wäre ja mehr, wenn das in die Schulter strahlt oder in den Rücken oder ins Bein.
Das wäre ausstrahlen, oder?
Ja, meine Frage, welcher Unterschied gibt es gewandert und ausstrahlen?
Bei gewandert hat der Schmerz ursprünglich an einer anderen Stelle begonnen und hat sich dann innerhalb von Stunden verlagert.
Meinst du, vom Bauchnabel hat er sich verlagert in den rechten Unterbauch, dann ist er gewandert.
Und wenn der Schmerz ausstrahlt, wie vielleicht bei der geilen Entzündung, dann kann er in die Schulter ausstrahlen zum Beispiel.
Zum Beispiel im Myokalternpaktus, koresistetes ausstrahlen, aber apandesitis urolitiasis gewandert.
Der Schmerz nicht gewandert, sondern der strahlt aus, vielleicht beim Herzinfarkt in die Unterkiefer oder in die Rechteam.
Dann strahlt er aus.
Ein Bandscheibenvorfall hat einmal den Schmerz im Rücken, aber mitunter den Hauptschmerz im Bein.
Aber apandesitis, am Anfang mittelbauch und dann rechten, gewandert.
Ja, dann ist er gewandert.
Zum Beispiel urolitiasis.
Ja, kann auch sein, ja.
Sondern bei Bauchbeschwerden gibt es ja häufiger, dass die Schmerzen mehr so von den Patienten im mittelbauch empfunden werden.
Und erst nach ein paar Stunden lokalisieren sie sich wirklich am Ort vielleicht des Geschehens, der Entzündung oder das.
Vielen Dank.
Bitte.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie solche Schmerzen erst mal gehabt?
Ja, das habe ich noch nie gehabt zu einem Schmerz.
Wann haben Sie letztes Mal etwas gegessen?
Vielleicht zehn Stunden.
Ich habe etwas trockenes Brot gegessen und etwas Tee getrunken, aber ich habe keinen guten Appetit jetzt.
Ich habe nur differenzial Diagnose, eine Frage gesteckt.
Sind dich, Melzen, am Anfang, beginn am Anfang, eine Stuhlgang gehen oder gehen Sie Gas ab?
Ja, aber da habe ich nicht, ist nicht auffällig.
Ich hatte den letzten Stuhlgang, hatte ich vor 10 Stunden, 12 Stunden vielleicht, 12 Stunden.
Aber ab Gas?
Ja, war relativ normal und alles ja auch ein bisschen, ein bisschen gase, aber das war alles normal.
Da habe ich auch keine Schmerzen gehabt dabei.
Nur differenzial Diagnose, diese Fragen müssen wir gesteckt, differenzial Diagnose oder Stuhlverhalt?
Ja, Stuhlverhalt, Wasserlassen, Stuhlgang, Wasserlassen, das ist wichtig, denke ich, ja genau.
War der letzte Stuhlgang vielleicht?
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Wie ist Ihre Regelbelutung?
Auf die Frage habe ich gewartet.
Ja, Frauen an einem Nese, ja, die fehlte.
Ja, diese Patienten sind sehr wichtig.
Wir sehen eine Mann und eine Schiebihare, das ist schwierig, das ist schwierig, ich muss mich den nächsten schminken.
Ja, ja, ja, unseh.
Aber das hätte ich als Oberarzt schon noch gefragt, bei der Vorstellung.
Das mache ich gleich an den Fragesteller, da steht bei mir das Name Sami.
Ja, Sami war der Fragesteller.
Das mache ich vielleicht gleich, wenn ich den Oberarzt spiele, ja.
Okay, gut.
Ja, wie sieht es aus, können wir?
Ja, gut.
Herr Oberarzt, haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ich möchte Ihnen über eine neue Patientin berichten.
Ja, klar.
Frau Ilona Klaprot ist eine 30-jährige Patientin,
die sich bei uns wegen Zeit 2.500 drücken,
rechtsseitiger Bauchsmärzung vorgestellt.
Die Patientin hat ein sehr schweres Haber,
und die Schmerzen würden im Becken ausstrahlen.
Wie in den rechten Unterbau?
In den rechten Unterbau ausstrahlen.
Zusätzlichkeit, die mit Schmerzen seben auf einer Schmerzschmerzschmerzseien.
Die Patienten sind auf die folgende Begleisungszentrum aufgefallen.
Ob die Blödsigkeit oder die Übelkeit.
Die haben die Piebe in den Mund gemessen.
Vorall, 38,5.
Sie haben Hypothyroidie.
Sie nehmen 50 mg Morgen ein.
Hat die Patientin Risikofaktoren bezüglich Baucherkrankungen?
Ist sie voroperiert am Bauch?
Keine Abdominellen-Obs.
Wie war bei der Patientin die letzte Periode?
Vor 25 Tagen.
Sie reagieren auf den Hautausflug.
Die Patientin hat seit 10 Tagen stärkeren Ausfluss.
Sie haben eine Frau.
Sie rauchen nicht.
Sie trinken ein Glas Wein am Wochenende.
Sie haben eine Diagnose.
Sie haben eine Morbus-Kron.
Sie haben eine Kokosatrose.
Sie haben eine Prakise.
Sie haben eine Osteoporose.
Sie haben eine chronische Erkrankung.
Sie haben eine Verdachter auf Appendicitis.
Sie haben eine Konferenzialdiagnostik.
Sie haben eine Erkrankung.
Sie haben eine Sonografie.